la collection high tech challenger ses
concorde
un avion de rêve qui tous les jours
franchi l'atlantique à plus de deux fois
la vitesse du son
outre magazine de la collection le monde
insolite des robots qui peu à peu nous
envahissent un peu plus dans notre vie
quotidienne
high tech challenger c'est aussi le tgv
est un voyage époustouflant à 515 km
heure
la haute technologie en vidéo c'est bien
sûr l'espace et tous ces satellites qui
gravitent nuit et jour où dessus de nos
têtes
le rafale l'avion invisible français et
bien d'autres aux technologies sont
aussi dans la collection high tech
challenge s
nous sommes en avril 1995 sur le pas de
tir numéro 3 de kourou en guyane
française
un événement pour les européens de
l'espace qui procède alors au premier
lancement de leur toute nouvelle fusée
ariane 5
c'est une fusée polyvalente de
conception entièrement nouvelle capable
pendant 20 ans de répondre à la fois aux
formidables défis des vols habités avec
en 2002-2003 le lancement de l'avion
spatial hermès mais aussi aux demandes
du marché mondial des satellites avec la
mise sur orbite par ariane 5 de monstres
de près de 70 on est bien loin en cette
fin du xxème siècle des 240 kg du
satellite franco allemand de
télécommunications symphonie qui au
milieu des années 70 marc est la
véritable naissance de l'europe de
l'espace symphonie ses dix ans après le
lancement du premier satellite
artificiel de la terre spoutnik 1 le 4
octobre 1957 le véritable point de
départ de la conquête de l'espace par
les européens pour les français l'espace
appelle alors à ma gear dans le sahara
leur centre de lancement diamant leurs
fusées et astérix leur premier satellite
qui ne pèse que 38 kg
pour répondre au milieu des années 60 à
la très forte demande en matière de
télécommunications la france et
l'allemagne décide de lancer en commun
le premier programme européen de
satellites de télécommunications ce sera
le programme symphonie
en 1967 un consortium industriel
franco-allemand est constitué il sera
formé de trois sociétés allemandes
mbb si mince et aeg et de trois sociétés
françaises aérospatiale thomson csf et
la sat
le consortium devra étudier développer
et construire un prototype et deux
modèles de vol le but essentiel du
programme symphonie étant de permettre
aux industriels des deux pays d'affirmer
leurs compétences dans le domaine des
satellites de télécommunications mais
aussi d'expérimenter très largement les
champs d'application et d'utilisation
futur de ce nouveau mode de transmission
au début des années soixante dix les
deux modèles de vol sont prêts reste à
trouver une fusée pour les lancer les
européens qui ne possède pas encore
ariane sont alors obligés de se tourner
vers les américains réponse de la nasa
d'accord mais à la condition expresse de
ne pas utiliser symphonie à des fins
commerciales mais seulement éducative et
expérimentale en 74 et en 75 les deux
satellites prendront ainsi le chemin de
cap canaveral et de l'espace
malgré les restrictions d'utilisation
imposées par les américains le programme
symphonie va être un véritable succès
technologique
dès la mise sur orbite des satellites
les résultats dépasse toutes les
espérances les plus optimistes pour la
première fois en europe des programmes
de télévision à caractère éducatif et
pédagogique sont transmis de france et
d'allemagne à destination des pays
d'afrique noire comme le gabon où la
côte d'ivoire
symphonie va permettre également
d'établir plusieurs programmes de
coopération avec divers pays désireux
d'utiliser ses satellites
ce sera le cas notamment avec l'inde et
l'organisation de recherche spatiale
isro
ce qui nécessitera le déplacement en
orbite d'un des deux satellites
symphonia de l'océan atlantique à
l'océan indien
symphonie c'est aussi désormais la
possibilité pour les européens de
communiquer avec les autres continents
en ce moment on va barder
malgré son aspect expérimental symphonie
aura permet aux industriels européens
tels aérospatiale thomson csf ou mbb de
se préparer à l'air naissante des
télécommunications modernes mais aussi
d'acquérir une notoriété internationale
leur permettant de remporter des grandes
compétitions mondiales comme la série
des intelsat 5
un drapeaux américains flottant à kourou
sur le centre spatial des européens
qui aurait pu imaginer cela quelques
années auparavant nous sommes en 1983 et
les européens s'apprêtent à lancer avec
ariane le premier satellite
international de la série intelsat 5 un
programme de coopération entre
l'américain ford aerospace le français
aérospatiale et l'allemand mbb avant le
départ d'intelsat pour l'espace comme
pour tous les satellites les ergots liés
en scaphandres autonomes vont remplir
ses réservoirs d'hydrazine le carburant
qui va permettre tout au long de la vie
du satellite dans l'espace de le
maintenir à poste à trente six mille
kilomètres par rapport à la terre
intelsat va ensuite être mis en place
tout en haut d'ariane puis il sera
enfermé dans une coiffe qui le protégera
lors de la traversée des couches denses
de l'atmosphère at elle sera de 5
c'est un monstre de près de 2 tonnes ou
comme un immeuble de deux étages capable
d'acheminer simultanément entre deux
continents
deux chaînes de télévision couleur et
12000 circuits téléphoniques en 25 ans
la masse des appels sat va passer de 40
kg pour le premier appelé à riber
l'oiseau du matin à près de 4 tonnes
pour la série actuelle des intelsat 6 le
prix des communications
intercontinentales ayant été pendant la
même période
/ 20 sur les qu'un satellite de la série
d un père saad 5 qui permettent
aujourd'hui encore les grandes
retransmission de télévision entre les
pays du monde entier
dix ont été lancées par des fusées
américaines atlas centaure 5 par ariane
permettre aux 21 pays de la ligue arabe
de communiquer entre eux de façon
moderne arabsat
c'est un satellite de communication
communautaire entre pays de même langue
de même culture et de même tradition
construit à cannes par aérospatiale
arabsat c'est une structure orbital
d'une tonne de au sol pour 600 kg en
orbite capable d'acheminer simultanément
8000 circuits téléphoniques et sept
programmes de télévision sur une zone
soigneusement délimitée du globe
terrestre celle des 21 pays de la ligue
arabe
arabsat comme tous les satellites doit
répondre dès son intégration à toute une
série de tests tests de vibration
reproduisant les contraintes dynamique
que devra subir le satellite lors de son
lancement test de choc thermique afin de
s'assurer que les structures seront bien
capable en orbite de résister aux
énormes différences de température entre
le jour et la nuit
août est de bon fonctionnement de
l'alimentation électrique du satellite
assurée par les vingt mille cellules des
panneaux solaires
une fois déclaré bon pour le service
arabsat comme tous les satellites des
mises en conteneur pressurisé puis
chargé à bord d'un avion cargo à
destination de cayenne
il y rejoindra la fusée ariane chargé de
lancer google est arrivé en guyane par
bateau en provenance de l'europe ou
ariane est construite
enfin c'est par convoi routier
exceptionnel que le satellite va
parcourir les 60 kilomètres qui séparent
l'aéroport de cayenne du centre spatial
guyanais
puis nouveau test dans des bâtiments
spéciaux à kourou afin de s'assurer une
dernière fois du bon fonctionnement du
satellite
comme il s'agit pour se dire d'un
lancement double cela vire de la mise
sur orbite de deux satellites par une
marianne arabsat va être placé à côté de
son compagnon de voyage ici brazil sat
les deux satellites vont être ensuite
transférés en zone de lancement aura
lieu pour la première fois la rencontre
satellite lanceur et c'est protéger sous
leur coiffe tout en å d'ariane que les
deux satellites attendront l'heure du
lancement
allez une fois les opérations de
lancement réussi ce sera aux équipes
d'exploitation et de contrôle de prendre
en main arabsat
durant toute sa vie orbital
quelque part au milieu de l'atlantique
les images météo de la terre et de son
atmosphère font désormais partie de
notre vie quotidienne
des images prises toutes les demi heures
par le satellites meteosat qui se trouve
en permanence sur l'équateur à trente
six mille kilomètres d'altitude au
dessus du golfe de guinée
des images transmises au centre des
opérations meteosat de darmstadt en
allemagne
image d'observation du disque terrestre
dans la bande visible mais aussi dans
l'infrarouge analysant plus
particulièrement soit la vapeur d'eau
qui entoure la terre soit les
températures des terres des océans et
des nuages dans la zone de couverture
les données brutes reçu à darmstadt sont
alors traitées de façon automatique afin
de corriger les différentes déformations
après analyse des images reçues on
calcule ensuite tous les paramètres
permettant de les exploiter
on établit ainsi avec précision les
éléments de base de la prévision comme
les vecteurs de déplacement des nuages
les températures de la surface des mers
l'humidité de la haute troposphère les
indices de précipitation ou l'analyse de
la couche nuageuse
c'est aujourd'hui à des satellites
européens de la série meteosat qui
assure en partie la veille météo des
états unis c'est l'organisation
intergouvernementale le médecin dont le
siège est à darmstadt en allemagne qui
exploite au système européen des
satellites météorologiques opérationnel
meteosat
ce voyage dans l'espace de météo sainte
et de deux autres satellites d'ici
angevins 88 par la première ariane 4
commence par la mise à feu des moteurs
de la fusée
une minute plus tard c'est la séparation
des deux propulseurs à poudre qui ont
aidé au décollage des 417 tonnes
d'ariane pratiquement le poids d'une
rame de tgv
deux minutes et demie après le décollage
c'est au tour des propulseurs cette fois
à carburant liquide de se séparer de la
fusée toujours propulsées par les quatre
moteurs de son premier étage séparation
du premier étage est à l'image du
deuxième ariane est déjà à près de 100
km d'altitude
après l'éjection de la coiffe c'est le
premier contact de meteosat avec le vide
spatial
moins de six minutes après avoir quitté
courroux séparation du deuxième étage et
allumage du troisième qui va alors brûlé
pendant douze longues minutes à l'issue
desquelles aura lieu l'injection ou si
l'on préfère la mise sur orbite le
troisième étage d'ariane et les trois
satellites qu'il propulse se trouve
alors à près de 300 km d'altitude et
6000 kilomètres de kourou sur
l'atlantique au dessus du golfe de
guinée
après avoir été mis en rotation et 20
minutes après son départ de kourou
meteosat est alors définitivement libéré
puis ce sera au tour du deuxième ici
awsat
un petit satellite pour radio amateur le
troisième étage valeur continue et son
balai dans l'espace afin d'éviter toute
collision avec paname sat un satellite
de télécommunications américain
ariane a terminé sa mission et c'est
maintenant aux stations sol de contrôle
des satellites de jouer
dix ans après avoir lancé ensemble le
programme symphonie français et
allemands décident en 1982 coopérer une
nouvelle fois à la réalisation d'un
programme de deux satellites aux
caractéristiques communes tdf pour la
france et tv sat pour l'allemagne un
programme de satellite de diffusion
directe des images de télévision
utilisant la norme des deux mc plus
performantes que les standards actuels
pâle ou ccam gage d'une qualité d'image
et de son
jusqu'à l'heure inconnues
c'est la construction de satellites de
conception modulaire qui est alors
décidé par le maître d'oeuvre euros
satellite une filiale commune
d'aérospatiale et d'alcatel espace pour
la france de m bébé amt et aeg pour
l'allemagne et au tc a pour la belgique
en octobre 88 après bien des discussions
au sein de la classe politique française
tf1 prendra le chemin de l'espace
l'intention pour des cons dix neuf huit
sept six cinq quatre trois deux un feu à
l'image des collages
vingt minutes après avoir quitté
courroux tdf 1 comme tout à l'heure
meteosat est maintenant en orbite sous
les ordres de la station sol chargés de
le contrôler pour t'aider f1 ce sera le
centre de contrôle du cnes de toulouse
qui devra le surveiller nuit des jours
et cela pendant une dizaine d'années la
durée de vie du satellite
c'est du sol qu'on va donner l'ordre par
télécommande au satellite de déployer
ses panneaux solaires
puis à plusieurs reprises d'allumer son
moteur d'apogée afin que son orbite ne
soit plus une ellipse mais qu'elles
décrivent dans laxe de l'équateur un
cercle parfait à trente six mille
kilomètres d'altitude au dessus de la
terre tdf 1 rejoindra alors seulement
son orbite appelé géostationnaire car
tournant à la même vitesse que la terre
tdf un semblera coming mobile dans le
ciel ordre sera alors donnée de
l'ouverture complète des panneaux
solaires fournissant l'énergie au sein
des lidd qui jusque là vivaient sur
celles de ses batteries puis tdf 1 sera
stabilisée sur ces trois axes dernière
opération avant l'ouverture et le
réglage précis des antennes d'émission
et de réception du satellite après le
savante manoeuvre de dérive
tdf 1 sera parfaitement stabiliser à 19
degrés ouest sur l'équateur seulement
alors pourrons commencer les premières
transmission d'image de télévision il se
sera pratiquement passé un mois depuis
le départ de cours ou de tdf 1 tdf un
pdf 2 et tv sat sont aujourd'hui tous en
orbite ainsi que telle et x leur frère
jumeau réalisé pour les pays nordiques
tdf un tdf2 c'est la réception directe
des images de télévision de très haute
qualité
une image cinéma beaucoup plus grande au
rapport 16/9 et aussi plusieurs canaux
sonore permettant la stéréophonie où les
coûts des programmes dans la langue de
son choix c'est la télévision haute
définition
venu de l'espace
non
donc
m
ça
ce que vous pourriez passer en toi tu es
il ya bien du temps en temps
les télécommunications spatiales à
l'échelle européenne c'est la sphère
d'eutelsat dans le siège et le centre
l'exploitation se trouve dans la tour
montparnasse à paris
son centre de contrôle est à rambouillet
peut-elle sat l'organisation européenne
de télévision par satellite compte
aujourd'hui 28 pays membres
les satellites de la série l'hôtel saab
deux de deuxième génération actuellement
en orbite sont des satellites de très
forte puissance capable d'acheminer
simultanément 17000 circuits
téléphoniques ou 16 chaînes de
télévision sur une très large zone de
diffusion dépassant les limites du
bassin méditerranéen
tout comme tdf peut-elle sa 2è de
conception modulaire une sorte de mécano
spatiale qu'on peut modifier en fonction
de la demande des clients
c'est ce qu'ont fait les industriels du
programme européen pour turksat en
proposant à la turquie un satellite de
télécommunication directement dérivée de
tels stades
organisé autour d'un tube central qui
assure la rigidité de l'ensemble est
abritée réservoir de carburant à
satellites de type peut-elle sa 2 c'est
une sorte de plateforme modulaire
constitué de systèmes spécialisés pour
la régulation thermique la propulsion la
télémesure et la télécommande le
contrôle d'attitude et orbite sans
oublier les deux immenses panneaux
solaires pour l'alimentation électrique
du satellite en orbite
un satellite de type peut-elle sa 2
c'est une masse de près de 2 tonnes dont
800 kg de carburant lui assurant 8 à 10
ans de vie un cube de deux mètres
cinquante de côté recouvert d'une sorte
de couverture dorée sur lequel viennent
s'accrocher de part et d'autre deux
grandes ailes de plus de 20 mètres
d'envergure
dernières pièces vitales d'un satellite
de télécommunications
le répéteur et les deux antennes sortes
de grands miroirs qui permet de recevoir
les signaux des stations de télévision
de les amplifier
avant de les réexpédier vers la terre à
destination de téléspectateurs
nous
en fonction de la demande peut-elle 7,2
peu par à faisceau large couvrir
l'ensemble du continent ou par un
faisceau de grande puissance concentrée
son rayonnement sur l'ouest et le centre
de l'europe
eutelsat du ces pour les années 90 un
programme de six satellites permettant
aux européens de communiquer entre eux
scruter le ciel aux confins de l'univers
c'est la mission d'iso un satellite
scientifique d'observation dans
l'infrarouge qui compte tenu de la
précision demandé aux optiques nécessite
plus que tout autre pour son élaboration
des précautions draconiennes de propreté
un lieu plus propre que n'importe quel
bloc chirurgical la moindre poussière
sur un miroir ayant des conséquences
catastrophiques pour les observations
futur pour détecter les très faible
émission infrarouge des sources
lointaines de l'univers le télescope
d'iso devrait être en permanence
refroidi aux limites du possible à moins
de 170 degrés à 3 degrés kelvin proche
du zéro absolu
une observation de la matière froides de
l'univers les planètes astéroïde
poussière des systèmes stellaires et des
milieux galactique ou enveloppes des
toiles un monde jusqu alors
inaccessibles aux télescopes
traditionnels dont la vision est
irrémédiablement perturbée par
l'atmosphère terrestre
scruter l'univers invisible c'est le
rôle du zoo un satellite développé par
aérospatiale pour le compte de l'agencé
spatiale européenne
toutes ces technologies développées
notamment en matière de qualité des
moyens optiques de détection permettent
désormais de faire hélios le premier
satellite d'observation militaire
français qui servira également à
l'italie et à l'espagne
l'observation de la terre par satellite
à des fins civiles ou militaires est
devenu aujourd'hui pour les puissances
spatiales une obligation directement
dérivée de spots qui de son orbite
située à 850 km au-dessus de la terre
peut voir des détails de 20 mètres de
côté en couleur et de 10 mètres en noir
et blanc
hélios dont le pouvoir de résolution et
classifiés secret défense aura sans
aucun doute une vue encore plus perçante
on parle d'identification de l'ordre de
quelques mètres
helios tout comme spot aura une orbite
polaire
c'est à dire qu'il surveillera en
permanence la terre en passant par ces
deux pôles
analysant au sol les moindres mouvements
observations optique puis d'ici la fin
du siècle
l'observation radar ou par infrarouge la
deuxième génération d'hélios pourrait
être ainsi opérationnel de nuit comme de
jour
avec la sonde huygens du nom de
l'astrophysicien qui en 1656 a découvert
la nôtre saturn
c'est le monde fabuleux des satellites
d'un autre genre celui des sondes
interplanétaires dont la mission est de
parcourir l'univers dans le seul but de
faire progresser la connaissance
après un voyage de sept ans à bord du
véhicule spatiale cassini réalisée par
la nasa
la sandwich sera littéralement éjecté de
cassini et dirigé vers titan le plus
gros des dix sept satellites naturels de
la planète saturne titan une sphère
orange encore bien mystérieuse de 5000
kilomètres de diamètre
al'approche de la haute atmosphère de
titan la sonde huygens dans sa course
vertigineuse sera alors freiné avant de
poursuivre sa descente au bout d'un
parachute
avant de s'écraser sur titan huygens
n'aura alors que quelques heures pour
décrire ce monde qu'on pense aujourd'hui
glace et à l'atmosphère opaque mais dont
la composition pourrait être voisine de
l'atmosphère primitive de la terre
pendant toute la mission de wiggins le
véhicule spatiale cassini restera en
orbite autour de saturne servant ainsi
de relais vers la terre aux informations
recueillies par la sonde pendant sa
descente vers titans le départ de la
planète terre pourrait avoir lieu en
novembre 1995 pour un atterrissage sur
titan au début de 2003
le monde fabuleux des satellites c'est
enfin celui des vaisseaux spatiaux
habités en orbite basse
évoluant entre 300 et 500 km seulement
de la terre si aujourd'hui ce les
soviétiques à bord de leur station
orbitale mir vivent en permanence dans
l'espace demain pour le reste du monde
l'avenir s'appelle freedom la station
orbitale internationale de la fin des
années 90 pour les européens
l'espace habité c'est columbus le
laboratoire orbital où qu'elle viendra
s'arrimer de temps à autre hermès
l'avion spatial chargé de transporter
hommes et matériaux vers ces stations du
futur
des infrastructures spatiales en orbite
appelé m6 et volant la vitesse de 30
mille kilomètres heure par rapport à la
terre qui auront leur zone de travail de
repos et de loisirs
pour assurer la sécurité des citoyens de
l'espace on a même imaginé une sorte d'
ambulance ou véhicules d'urgence capable
de rapatrier très rapidement sur terre
ces voyageurs au long cours
ces véritables cités du ciel du
troisième millénaire sorte de villes
satellites de la banlieue de la terre
deviendront alors les stations-service
des sondes interplanétaires des relais
spatiaux abritant le temps d'une étape
leurs équipages en route pour d'autres
planètes
en 2010 ces immenses satellite de la
terre pourrait être le point de départ
des hommes partant établir des colonies
permanente sur la lune et dix ans plus
tard en 2020
il pourrait voir passer d'autres sommes
en route vers la planète mars